[Music]
she's gonna be some love it's all about
love really in musical theater yes love
is in the air in the flash and
supergirls musical crossover and only et
was on set with the stars for all the
romantic details I understand that there
might be a handsome alien who's really
trying to get you out of this dream
sequence and back to reality is that
true I would say I would say there are a
few people trying to pull us out of now
iris and Montel are sort of teaming up
and they're like we love these guys I'm
they're not here what should we do let's
help let's help them cuz that's a great
thing to do in musicals wait oh I'm
sensing that we need a little like cross
universe double date yes I think I think
Barry in the car I should set up that
real date what would that look like
where would they go yeah Irish is the
only non superpower person involved in
that before something right and they're
both super strong and I'm super fast so
is that a factor planning the state for
some reason I think like rollerskating
and lowering would be funny especially
with Barry Allen what is their ship name
Oh West Ellen that's not a desert it's
very sweet yes but not as sweet as
caramel because by the way that is the
best ship name
Oh caramel how could you not it's just
Alysha Street that goes on everything in
the chief and I think it might be I
think it might be you know last season
she learned how to be Supergirl and now
she's coming into her own more as an
adult and
the balancing love with everything goes
with that so I love it I think it's a
really sweet thing that she's learning
about herself are you a fan of their
relationship I don't I I you know what
I'm a fan of car being happy
OTP yeah okay OTP Oh TA wonder alien one
true alien that's great that's great
high five
[Laughter]
[Music]
you